I am thankful for my family and friends
I'm also thankful that I've been given a
gift that I work well with children and
I'm helping them dyslexic children learn
how to read the love of family and
friends and living in a great community
for a working artists like this one is
I'm thankful for my family and my
friends and what's left of nature i'm
really thankful for that I'm thankful
that Hillary got more votes than shrimp
overall I'm very grateful that the state
i live in voted for hillary because that
makes me feel a little bit safer in this
community what do I hope for in the next
four years I would like an impeachment
of both of them what I'm hoping for for
the next four years is a lot of unity
and a lot of love I think we have to
take this time of difficulty and
soul-searching as an opportunity to do
you know so it's coming I can feel it